si
[Música]
alguna vez has dicho mañana voy a hacer
ejercicio y llega el día de mañana suena
la alarma y dices hay forma de que
flojera no te preocupes no estás solo el
72% de los mexicanos que no hacen
ejercicio dicen que es por flojera
cansancio o falta de tiempo lo que
también es curioso es que el 95 por
ciento de los hijos de las 500 empresas
más valiosas del mundo así como el 72%
de los presidentes de los eeuu en los
últimos 100 años coinciden en que el
deporte es parte esencial de su vida
yo no te voy a decir cómo llegar a ser
presidente o como sencillo pero sí como
a través del deporte encontré tres
puntos clave para lograr el equilibrio
en mi vida
todo empezó desde muy pequeño cuando
grand slam hiperactividad mis papás me
metieron a predicar todo tipo de
deportes lo cual resultó bastante bien
porque el deporte se volvió parte
esencial de mi vida
cuando llegó el momento de entrar a la
universidad claro que también tenía que
escoger un deporte el básquetbol me
había cautivado en los últimos años de
la preparatoria por lo que esa fue mi
primera opción
fui a las pruebas para entrar el equipo
y terminando el coach me dice oye por
qué no vas a probar el fútbol
ahorita forma de batear menos pero pues
allá voy voy a la prueba de fútbol la
termino y que me vuelven a batear sale
pero casualmente un amigo me invita a
practicar un deporte nuevo el rugby lo
primero que se me vino a la mente fue
este cúbito de colores cuando en
realidad es un poco más como esto
escuela nueva materias nuevas amigas
nuevos por qué no probar un deporte
nuevo
así que hoy entusiasmado a la prueba
para entrar el equipo lago y terminando
el coach me dice algo que yo no esperaba
escuchar me dice si tú en un año no
estás en la selección nacional yo
renuncio caray apenas escuché las
palabras selección nacional en mis ojos
empezaron a brillar el sueño de toda mi
vida había sido representar a méxico
frente a todo el mundo
pero en un deporte nuevo que apenas
conocía nunca había practicado un
deporte de contacto como pueden ver es
una persona bastante flaca exactamente
treinta kilos abajo de mi peso actual
pero decidí darle una oportunidad
empecé con dos entrenamientos a la
semana y luego tres luego cinco en un
abrir y cerrar de ojos estaba entrenando
alrededor de 30 horas a la semana ya no
era sólo un pasatiempo pero como muchos
los deportistas en este país esa no era
mi única responsabilidad
la escuela mis amigos la familia el
trabajo la nutrición y claro el
transporte por la caótica ciudad de
mexico
al principio logré manejarlo bastante
bien pero llegó un momento en el que ya
no pude más
y pues era una clase viendo el tema de
productividad me topé con la siguiente
frase cuando dices que no tienes tiempo
lo que realmente está diciendo es que no
es una prioridad pues bueno yo ya no
tenía tiempo tenía que escoger qué era
una prioridad para mí me empezaba a las
5 de la mañana y terminaba a las 12 de
la noche
y realmente ya no sabía qué hacer cómo
sacarle más más tiempo al tiempo por lo
cual esa fue mi primera el primer punto
para encontrar el equilibrio en la vida
el ver el fijar mis prioridades de forma
armoniosa
en ese momento de crisis me di cuenta
que yo no quería ser un atleta un
profesionista un estudiante por separado
yo quería ser una persona de alto
rendimiento capaz de mantener los
aspectos más importantes de mi vida al
mejor nivel posible logrando que ccoo
existieran llevando lo aprendido de la
cancha hacia el trabajo a la escuela mis
amigos y viceversa y viceversa todo
trabajando todo conviviendo de forma
armoniosa así como los engranes de un
reloj en donde si bien cada uno tiene
sus propias características
todos trabajan hacia un mismo objetivo
hubo eventos reuniones eventos
familiares se les hubiera encantado ir
pero que tuve que decir que no por
estudiar por entrenar o simplemente
descansar
perdí supuestos amigos
pero me quedé con la gente que realmente
importaba y con los con las prioridades
que realmente sumaban hacia mis sueños
al haber escogido esas prioridades en mi
vida yo al ser una persona muy visual
las coloque en una gráfica les puse una
ponderación a lo largo de las distintas
etapas de mi vida para así a través de
tres sencillos pasos poder poder definir
cuáles serían las prioridades de cada
día el primero en ubicar la prioridad
del momento tan sencillo como trazar una
línea vertical de arriba hacia abajo en
esta gráfica de mi vida en el momento en
el que me encontrara y con la primera
actividad que meto para esa sería la
cual tendría la prioridad tendría el
objetivo tendría la energía y recursos y
el tiempo de de mí
el segundo punto sería el siguiente que
me encontrara en esta línea vertical y
así paso a paso en caso de que tuviera
dos actividades que se toparán en la
misma prioridad del momento el criterio
de desempate sería la relevancia el
futuro saber qué impacto tendría las
actividades que tomo en ese momento en
el futuro de juan pablo y así poder
desempatar 2 aquí es que en ese momento
parecería que fuera al igual de
importantes para mí el tercer punto el
observar el entorno algo vital hoy en
día estamos en un mundo constante en
constante cambio que cambia rápidamente
y que tenemos que adaptar al entorno en
el que nos encontramos por más que el
plan o la estrategia la llevamos hecho
un día anterior una semana anterior el
momento de ejecutarlo y hacer algo
distinto
y bueno esta metodología fue la que me
llevaría a cumplir el objetivo que me
puso mi coche en un principio en 11
meses llegué a cumplir mi sueño de
representar a méxico de forma
internacional un momento indescriptible
récord y se recién poniendo la piel de
gallina no lo podía creer estaba
cumpliendo un sueño pero mi historia no
termina ahí de hecho apenas era el
comienzo lo que me lleva al segundo
punto para el encontrar el equilibrio en
mi vida el ver que los sueños no son un
fin únicamente sino un medio
si algo me ha enseñado el deporte es que
si baso mi felicidad en cumplir o no un
sueño sería feliz alrededor de cinco
minutos en toda mi vida
pero que sí en cambio encuentro la
felicidad en cada parte del proceso en
cada momento del día en esa friega de
despertarse temprano en el tener que
correr de la escuela al trabajo al
gimnasio y de vuelta al entrenamiento
regresar y tener que hacerme de comer al
disfrutar cada parte del proceso podría
ser feliz cada día de mi vida
al haber cumplido mi sueño de
representar a méxico
fácilmente lo puede ver tachado de mi
lista y cambiado de rumbo pero me di
cuenta que los sueños están hechos para
ser eternos y la forma de hacerlos
eternos
es el de verlos como un medio para
alcanzar algo mucho más grande que el
simple hecho de lograr ese sueño
es por eso que hoy estoy seguro en mi
sueño no terminara incluso cuando ya no
pueda jugar más porque ya habrá
trascendido ese sueño a los distintos
aspectos de mi vida y con suerte también
la de los demás ya habré dejado un
legado en el deporte mexicano al haberlo
dejado un escalón arriba de como yo lo
encontré en un principio y eso lo hace
eterno
finalmente el tercer punto para lograr
el equilibrio en mi vida el ver el
fracaso como parte del proceso yo creo
que todos nos imaginamos cumpliendo
nuestros sueños de cierta forma
romántica no el ir caminando por la
calle el ver esa persona especial y
saber que es el amor de tu vida el
encontrarte ese magnate de los negocios
en el elevador y en 30 segundos lograr
tu trabajo ideal o para él para el caso
de un artista el llegar al evento más
importante de su vida y tener una
participación perfecta en mi caso los
juegos panamericanos el evento deportivo
más grande de todo el continente
un ambiente increíble estadios repletos
rodeándome con esos atletas que solía
ver en la televisión hace unos meses
mi papá y mi hermano viéndome desde las
gradas mi familia y amigos apoyándome de
esa casa
viviendo el sueño realmente ya me veía
yo anotando para ganar el torneo
saliendo en hombros por mis compañeros
lleno de aplausos haciendo historia para
méxico pero lo que nunca me imaginé es
que terminar el torneo siendo humillado
e insultado por un compañero en pleno
partido por cometer un error
la es que ese momento de marco de por
vida
porque aprendí que un momento de fracaso
no te define como fracasado pero como
tomás el fracaso si define cómo afrontas
el futuro en ese momento yo decidí tomar
el fracaso no solo como un maestro sino
como un aliado para salir de las sabanas
en esos días que no te quieren dejar
escapar para ponerme entrenar en esos
días que no tienes ni tantas ganas para
tener las fuerzas de decir que no a esas
fiestas por quedarte a cumplir con tus
responsabilidades
porque la motivación también sale de los
momentos difíciles
es por eso que hoy te invito a decirle
que no a cuatro cosas a no olvidarte
disfrutar lo que tienes ahora porque no
sabemos lo que nos depara el futuro a no
dejar de luchar por tus sueños por miedo
al fracaso
a no buscar dejar una huella sino a
plantar una semilla para tener un futuro
mejor
ya no dejar el ejercicio fuera de tus
prioridades porque es la mejor forma de
amar a tu cuerpo
es por eso que hoy te pido
que no busques que no que no te pierdas
en ese en esas ganas de ver que todo el
mundo vea lo que te interesa de lo que
vea lo que estudiaste que vea lo que te
apasiona porque somos un conjunto de
todo lo que la gente ve y mucho más que
busques tener el equilibrio personal
para que puedas salir y busques el
equilibrio del mundo necesita gracias